Bread Day is a beautiful day.
It is our opportunity to work with the children through song...
...and the grains that grow in the fields.
And so the children are actually taking part in the beginnings of a magical creation...
...or a science experiment.
They watch the yeast grow.
How does that grow?
What is that?
Why does it do that?
This is one of the ways in Waldorf education that we are teaching...
...adult principles for later in life, for flexibility in thinking.
And then once we have the dough, we gently roll it together.
Each one makes a bun.
In this, there's that opportunity to experience the life in that...
...so that food is not an object but is an experience.
And so we're taking part in the care of feeding our cozy cottage,...
...which is what I call our kindergarten.
We are really enjoying the love of each other...
...and in rolling the bread and experiencing community.